un an un an déjà que la france s'est
renfermé chez elle confine et angoissé
par la pandémie du coronavirus le
gouvernement décide alors de fermer les
bars lieux culturels magasins non
essentiels un événement historique
comment l'avez vous vécu paul boyer et
lucas chopard vous ont posé la question
ce matin
la france vit un moment très difficile
nul ne peut en prévoir précisément la
durée
c'était il ya un an la france
s'apprêtait à être confinés et avec elle
les espoirs d'une sortie de crise rapide
mais si certains ont souffert de la
situation
d'autres s'y sont rapidement accommoder
[Musique]
des déchets mois à saint cyr j'étais
chez moi
voilà devant la télé on s'attendait un
peu à l'annoncé des amis on était en
train de c'était un soir on était en
train de dîner ensemble donc on avait
allumé la télé pour voir un petit peu ce
qui allait se passer et on était un
petit peu sous le choc on va dire est ce
que le confinement moi m'a beaucoup gêné
j'avais pas tant que ça ce que mon style
de vie et déjà tu voudrais confirmer
volontaires c'était un petit peu rigolo
de se dire bah alors que qu'est ce qu'on
va faire chez soi enfermé a pas sortir
et puis bon au bout de deux mois c'est
cette venue très long quand même j'ai
pas vu grand monde j'ai même vu
pratiquement personne n'a pas un peu mes
voisins c'était très angoissant
cette solitude il a par le côté
financier qui était compliqué
personnellement j'ai trouvé que c'était
comme un exercice un peu quelque chose
de nouveau
j'ai essayé de positiver et c'était
assez agréable quand même jardinage
bricolage
chacun y est allé de ses astuces pour
faire passer le temps plus rapidement
côté travail en revanche le premier
confinement a misé à mal bien des
projets
comme je suis indépendant et que je
travaille dans le milieu de la musique
c'est compliqué parce que tous les
concerts qu'ils s'arrêtent tous les
événements qui s'arrête donc moi j'ai
été impacté directement je venais de
d'embauché pour un travail dans un hôtel
et donc je me suis vite retrouvé au
chômage partiel
j'ai travaillé six mois en main mais
c'est pas fameux actuellement sac en
tant que débutant dans un domaine où il
ya pas mal de concurrence bah ça tacle
un peu quoi un an après tous se
souviennent du premier confinement comme
d'un événement historique et gardent
l'espoir d'entrevoir le bout du tunnel
prochainement